if you had the flexibility to blow  yourself would you i mean yeah what what  are we doing here  you want me to go through the rest of  the question fine what if everybody knew  you did i'd be like  [ __ ] i'm how long you know how long  of a jealous line that would be  if everyone knew i sucked my own dick i  probably would put that i would change  my name to  dan i can suck my own dick soda i'll put  it on my driver's license when i'm  getting in the bars though like you suck  your own dick i'm like you want to see  it  if i have to watch me time to watch it  five to watch tend to watch me finish  and then you'll have to watch me boa  constrict my load  is that too graphic i don't know you get  the picture  you